so we could have a sex and gender split
as as the as the political types insist
that's also grounded in biological
differences without making a categorical
distinction absolutely
they always remain connected
the reason that we have genders and to
have a duality of gender
is because we have sexes
so people who say that gender is purely
in our heads is purely
it's a society product
that's an impossibility i think if we
were a cloning species
so we had no sexual reproduction
where we would all be identical no one
would have come up with the concept of
gender
[Music]
hello everyone i am really thrilled even
more than usual
because i'm usually thrilled with my
guests
to
be talking to dr
franz dewall
dr dewall is a dutch
american biologist and primatologist
known for his work on the behavior and
social intelligence of our closest
biological relatives he is ch candler
professor emeritus at emory university
and distinguished professor emeritus at
utrecht university
his scientific work has been published
in hundreds of technical articles in
journals such as science
nature scientific american and outlet
specialized in animal behavior and i
should point out that generally speaking
in a scientist's career even a single
publication in a journal such as science
or nature is uh it can be the pinnacle
of a career and to do that multiple
times is
pretty rare and so dr dual is a
scientist who's in many ways in the
league of his own
his popular books translated into more
than 20 languages have made him one of
the world's most visible primatologists
and scientists i would say his latest
two books of many and i'll mention some
others are mama's last hug
norton 2019 and different gender through
the eyes of her primatologist which was
published by norton in 2022. he's been
elected to the u.s national academy of
sciences as well as the royal
netherlands academy of arts and sciences
in 2007 time declared him one of the
world's 100 most influential people
today now i would also say
um
that i'm particularly thrilled to be
talking to dr d wall because he's his
work has had a real influence on my
thought now i'm not so hap sure how
happy he might be about that but
uh he is one of the world's deepest
thinkers on
a variety of important issues perhaps
most importantly
on the
biological basis of morality the
development of morality and his work on
the development of the moral sentiments
you might say in chimpanzees and moral
behavior and his analysis of
hierarchical behavior in chimpanzees and
bonobos is i think revolutionary not
only biologically but also
philosophically and that's something he
has delved into
i would say
uh equally that's the case for his work
on play and his work on
gender
uh
de waal is one of the few people
who have made a really solid case for a
specifically sophisticated view of the
construction let's say of hierarchies in
primates which are often pilloried say
with regards to chimpanzees as
predicated on something like brute force
and power and the fact that the wall
has indicated quite clearly that that is
a
insufficient to say the least view of
the complexity of such hierarchical
organization is work of tremendous
importance partly because it allows for
the union in some real sense of
is and ought because
that's an old philosophical conundrum
can we derive an ought from an is and
and the answer to that is not in any
simple way but the fact does remain that
there are
elements of social organization in our
closest primate
relatives that do shine some light on
the biological
foundations of ethics itself
his work on peacemaking among primates
is also signally important in my
estimation
i've read about seven of his books uh
peacemaking among primates i thought
that was a great book that was 1989
chimpanzee cultures which he edited with
richard rangham who's another guest on
my show another great primatologist good
natured the origins of right and wrong
in humans and other animals another
great book bonable the forgotten ape an
analysis of
another very close relative of ours
biologically speaking genetically
speaking who
but as a chimp subtype in some sense or
an ape subtype that organizes its social
community quite differently than
than chimpanzees he wrote mama's last
hug as i mentioned before animal
emotions what they tell us about
ourselves are we smart enough to know
how smart animals are which is another
great book and most recently different
gender through the eyes of a
primatologist i would highly recommend
to all of those who are watching and
listening that you pick up any or all of
dr dewall's books they're extremely
they're very straightforward they're
easy to read they're deep they're well
grounded in a
multi-dimensional in the scientific
literature in a multi-dimensional manner
i think he's one of the world's most
important psychologists even though
that's not his primary field his books
are a delight to read and uh
i've
he certainly influenced my thinking more
than anyone else with the hand exception
of a handful of people like yock pancett
who's done great work on similar grounds
with rats in uh
in the in the realm of biology so i'm so
thrilled to have you on today so thanks
for
a quick gushing and we'll get to it
you're welcome
thanks for all the praise
yeah well i mean it's it wasn't praised
man it's uh
it's uh it's the truth uh your work has
been
un of unbelievable interest to me
especially on the as i said especially
on the front of the development of
morality so maybe we could you want to
start with just maybe a little bit of
bio and just tell everyone
how what you do where and how you
developed what you do you said for
example that you were influenced by nico
tinberger and maybe we could just go
through the whole ethology
uh
background and make it personal and then
we'll get to get down to brass tacks
after that
well nicotine william was a dutch
etologist ethologists are biologists who
study behavior of animals
mostly naturalistic behavior so that was
a big difference with skinner let's say
in the psychology who who put rats in
the box and that compressed levels the
ethologists wanted to have natural
behavior that they looked at
and
tin bagger was a dutchman i'm a dutchman
i'm from the same school basically even
though i'm not a direct student of his
and um i was trained to observe animals
that's mostly in the beginning of my
career that's what i did i observed
animals observed chimpanzees bonobos
other animals
and then later when i moved to the u.s
in the 1980s i moved first to wisconsin
and worked with monkeys there and then i
moved to emory much uh 10 years later
i started to do experiments behavioral
experiments not invasive studies just um
a chimp would come out of a group into a
room and do something on a touch screen
or was a tool or or whatever the
experiment was
and so later i started to do more
experimental approaches
and got interested in very different
behaviors such as reconciliation after
fights or empathy
how they respond to the distress of
others
um
and so i developed ideas about
cooperation and empathy in a time
that people were still
quite a bit focused on competition and
aggression and violence which was the
early focus of ethology really
right so there was this assumption that
that was held long i would say
across animal species
that who who organized themselves into a
social community that the social
hierarchy which is almost an inevitable
consequence of a community was
predicated on something like dominance
hence the word dominance hierarchy i had
a graduate student about or he's a
colleague of mine now but about seven
years ago he told me that i should stop
using the word dominance hierarchy and i
asked him why because i used that phrase
a lot and he said well dominance is when
you put a chain around someone's neck
and they're naked and you and you can
lead them around and you can get them to
do anything you want and our hierarchies
our functional hierarchies are not based
on dominance and then he said and i
think that that's that idea is a
consequence of the invasion of
marxist-derived ideas implicitly into
the biological domain and like it really
took me about because i had used that
term a lot and i thought oh he's really
on to something there because
i think our hierarchies when they're
functional are predicated on competence
and reciprocity and it's only when they
become pathological that they're based
on power and then i came across your
work which well was before that too
and you well and i would like you to
talk about that so let's talk about the
hierarchical the social organization of
chimpanzees on the male and female side
and what you've observed yeah so the the
dominance relationship is a two-way
street you know so
it's very hard to dominate a bunch of
people who don't want to be dominated or
don't want to be led so it's always you
have the followers
and and the ones who are dominant but
the idea that dominance is purely based
on coercion and power
is i think simplistic
you need a party who wants to be
dominated and and in order to be
dominated you need to give them certain
things also
so
the dominant is not
purely
coercive
it does happen i call them usually
bullies and we have them in human
society too it does happen
also in chimpanzee society that a male
is
just big and strong and and orders
others around
that kind of meals are not very popular
and uh
the group is basically waiting for a
challenger and if a challenger comes up
then they're going to support the
challenger they want to get rid of a
male like that
yeah well you one of the things that's
so revolutionary about that i believe on
the philosophical front is that i think
your work as well as panceps with rats
has shown that that kind of coercion and
power
actually constitutes a very unstable
basis for social organization and that
if you engage in that as you said you'll
gain enemies and and that even happens
at the animal level in some real
sophisticated sense and the probability
that as you've also
described
when you're a bully
and you have an off day
two of the
two of your subordinates that you're
that you've bullied can do a pretty good
job of tearing you into pieces yeah yeah
yeah yeah so the
the stable alpha male and and most alpha
males that i've known in chimpanzees
they
they break up fights they keep the peace
they defend the underdog so they defend
a juvenile against an adult or a female
against the male
they
are empathic actually they they
reassure individuals who are
distressed and they can they can become
extremely popular so people always
imagine that the alpha male must be
frightening and that everyone is scared
of them
there is a certain respect for them so
there is a certain fear involved
but they can be extremely popular
and so um
yes and that that's that indication of
stability you know because so this is
one of the things that's so key
do you know about yak pancep's work on
play with rats i know banks have yeah
okay i knew him yeah but
he died a couple of years ago but i knew
him yeah sure so you know that he showed
that if you repeatedly put juvenile
males together to play
that the larger rat can dominate the
smaller rat with no problem but if the
the larger rat doesn't let the little
rat win
30 percent of the time across repeated
play bouts then the little rat will stop
playing yeah and so that surprised me
yeah well it's so cool you know to see
that alongside your work because it it
it's one of these indications as far as
i'm concerned that
the rules that govern a single
interaction which might be that i can
win by dominance are not the same rules
that govern repeated interactions within
a social context and your work has done
a lovely job of fleshing out the
sophisticated complexity of behavior and
attitude necessary even at the
chimpanzee level so that the troop
remains stable because you also
described how when there's
violence between two males say
vying for for
status shift and a better position that
the entire troop gets agitated and that
part of the regulation of that
male violence that can spiral out of
control is actually distributed into the
social community yes so but what happens
is that it's also in the way you become
dominant how do you reach the top
position often in a in a chimp society
that is with the support of others
and so um i i can become the alpha male
but i may have need one one or two male
supporters i may need female support
and as a result also i need to be nice
to my supporters because if i'm not nice
to them they will stop supporting me and
my position is based on them as a result
you can also get
the smallest male can be the alpha male
that happens sometimes in a chimpanzee
group is the smallest male is the
dominant male and and you wonder how
that happens but that's because he has
supporters
it also means that a female
can be very powerful like i described in
my previous book mama's last hug mama
the alpha female who was alpha for for
40 years and so she saw a lot of males
come and go
and she was crucial in in the alpha male
business and so if a male wanted to be
the dominant male he needed her support
because he had the support of all the
females and so it's almost like a
democratic system in that sense is that
you need the support of others and you
need to keep your supporters happy so
it's a very different
people have this
one-sided view which comes from the
early baboon studies i think they have
this view of of the male who dominates
everyone and orders everyone around
but that's really a simplistic view and
it applies maybe to these baboons but
certainly not the chimp supernovas yeah
well that that that that your work also
highlights the crucial importance
and multi-species importance of
something like the principle of
reciprocity right and you use words like
nice and empathic which
and and then you justify that we can
talk about about that so-called
anthropomorphism as we go along but the
idea that
a stable society and also
the
also that the idea that the individuals
that that make up that society are
psychologically stable and that would be
not to stress let's say that that
depends intrinsically on a degree of
mutuality and reciprocity that that's
really a revolutionary idea to ground
that in biology yeah reciprocity is very
important because uh
the alpha male if he has a supporter who
keeps him in that position then he needs
to give that supporter a lot of things
otherwise
what would be in it for the supporter
you know well what kind of things do you
see the alpha doing
in this more reciprocal sense well the
typical situation is that the alpha male
is dependent on another male he he will
let the other male matrix females
which is which is what dominance is
really all about among the males is that
access to females and so he may be
intolerant to every other male and keep
them away from females but his buddy who
made him alpha he let them meet with his
females because if he doesn't and they
said i've seen this happen if he doesn't
then his body will revolt and will stop
supporting him right so that that also
indicates so you know you might ask
yourself why
the instinct to allow
for reciprocal dominance
exists in human beings given that access
to mating
privileges is such a crucial
element of
of reproduction but if part of that is
is that if we can make coalitions with
our support superordinates say
make coalitions even though we're not
dominant and
that ability to form
coalitions upward is associated with
sexual access because the the dominant
male chimps they chase other males away
from the females right the females will
mate this is something that makes them
different than human females the the
female chimps will mate with pretty much
any male when they're in estrus if i
understand it properly but the more
dominant males will ch no is that wrong
yeah the females
there's a big issue with female choice
as we call it females have preferences
for certain males
and these preferences don't need to
correspond with the male hierarchy and
so um
we used to think that the dominant male
would sire most offspring because we saw
them
the dominant males made more often than
other males but females do all sorts of
things uh
behind the bushes and at night
and so we now know from paternity
testing
that the dominant male is not always the
one who has the most offspring and and
that is that is because females have
preferences different preferences
right right is the would you say okay so
so let me let me update myself in
relationship to that i understood my
understanding of the primatology
literature and insofar as it extended to
uh humans was that human females were in
some sense
uh unique in the degree to which they
exercised sexual choice with concealed
ovulation and so forth and that that was
part of perhaps what drove our rapid
departure away from chimpanzees let's
say on the cognitive front but you're
saying as well that
choice in in chimpanzee females female
choices
plays a more important role than might
have originally been uh predicted i
think it started with the birds you know
we we have monogamous birds songbirds
male female and they have nestle's eggs
and um we've always assumed that the
male was the father of all these
fertilized all the eggs
but now since paternity testing this
started in the 1970s we know that
if you look at
the eggs you very often find extra pair
uh males in there so so so different
males who have mated with the female
initially the biologists assumed very
victorian type of assumption they
assumed that
of course the female was probably raped
by other males or something like that
but now we know that the females
actively look for sex with other males
and so the in the birth literature it's
very well known and we we distinguish
social monogamy from genetic genetic
monogamy and and most of the monogamy
that we see is social it's not
necessarily genetic in the sense that
the male is the father of all the
offspring
now and since then we have now lots of
studies on other animals including the
primates that we know for example a
female chimpanzee
see mates with many more males than you
would then would be necessary to be
fertilized she mates with lots of males
uh and she has certain preferences that
that we now learn about that theme it's
called female choice and that's a big
literature on on
on female behavior so females have very
often preferences that deviate from the
male hierarchy and yeah so
so let me let me push you on that a bit
so i looked at human studies and the
correlation between sexual success and
socioeconomic status for men
in relationship to sexual success with
women is about somewhere between point
six and point seven which is an
unbelievably stunningly high correlation
yes yeah it's like it's higher than the
correlation between intelligence and
academic performance for example which
is maybe the second highest correlation
of that sort we know and so
but but that shows in human beings that
the female preference and the male
hierarchy are pretty tightly aligned do
you how close are they aligned in chimps
and if they're not aligned what are the
females looking for that that isn't
signaled by the hierarchical structure
of the males
in humans of course the female
preference
has also to do with status and income
uh in the sense of uh resources
which is not so much the case in in
chimpanzees i would say because they
don't have a nuclear family structure
well and they don't obviously gather
resources to say yeah
yeah so we we humans
we humans have a nuclear family
structure so the males are involved in
the family and in caring for offspring
which is not really the case in bonobos
and chimpanzees and so
the human female has a more complex
picture in front of her
which includes maybe sexual preference
which may be
based on the body or the appearance and
so on but it also uh is based on uh she
also looks for resources so so i think
it's a more complex picture probably so
i'm curious about that too because tell
me what you think of this uh it seems to
me that although socioeconomic status
and mating success in human males is
very tightly associated that human
females aren't looking so much
for status or even socioeconomic
position they're using those as markers
for the ability to generate resources
and social status
and so because really what they want and
i think this is tied with your work on
reciprocity and uh
social skill in chimpanzees what what
the human females really want is
competence and generosity and they use
social status and
resource acquisition as a marker for
that yeah yeah that's very well possible
um
i'm not so familiar with with that human
literature but
there is a big field now of female
initiative
uh female choice
female sexuality you know
biology started out pretty victorian in
the sense that
female sexuality didn't exist females
were passive sexually
males were active and had a sex drive
but females basically didn't need it
that's that's how the biologists thought
about it and all that thinking has
changed
in my book on gender i talk quite a bit
about female sexuality and the size of
the clitoris and so on which is related
to that seeking pleasure and so on
and
i think it's it's highly significant
that we see that female chimpanzees and
certainly female bonobos
they have quite a bit more sex than is
necessary for uh strictly for
reproduction
so so they are very adventurous
um and the female bonobo has a big
clitoris bigger than the the human
female and the biggest one is in the
dolphin which is also a sexually
adventurous species
so um people are not paying attention to
that whereas we we went through a long
period where female sexuality were
basically ignored was irrelevant
so in the barnables particularly um
the the social organization differs from
that of the chimp quite markedly despite
the close genetic association between
the species and the bonnevilles have
often been portrayed as well let's say
hippie the hippie chimps because it's
free love sex and in some sense a more
matriarchal uh social structure so why
do you think those differences emerged
between those two subspecies and and i
know you've drawn lessons from both
are the are they species or subspecies
they can mate so how are they
technically defined well we do we do
call them species they belong to the
same genus
the bloopers are female dominated and
the female dominance is a collective
dominance a single female cannot
dominate a single male if if you see at
zeus that that happens sometimes that
you see one male and one female bonobo
which is of course very atypical um but
then the male is dominant as soon as you
add the second female the females become
dominant it's a collective dominance
that they have high level of female
solidarity uh surfaced by a lot of sex
and grooming between the females and
why they have this different society
i think it's made possible by the fact
that the females can travel together
there is enough food in their forest and
they don't have competition from
gorillas they don't live together these
gorillas in the forest that they have
more food available that allows the
females to travel together actually you
mentioned richard rangham some of these
are these ecological ideas come from
richard rangham is that the female
bonobo
they can stay together as a group and
that allows them to have this very
powerful sisterhood whereas the female
chimpanzees
and therefore as they need to spread out
in order to find enough food
and and so that kind of bonding that
happens in the in the bonobo is not
really possible for them
okay so this is this oh sorry go ahead
yeah and in captivity because i've
worked
of course mostly in captivity
in large chimpanzee colonies in in zoo
settings than the female chimps they are
actually very powerful because then
they're all together they're forced to
live together of course and then they
develop some sort of sisterhood it's not
as as well developed as in the bonobo
but the power difference between males
and females becomes very different in
captivity
okay well this is a good segue into the
sex and gender discussion so in your
book the difference with your new book
you distinguish as do
the more radical political types now sex
and gender and i was interested in that
for a variety of reasons so when i look
at that issue i look at it from the
perspective of a personality
psychologist so
i the notion that sex itself is binary
is fine with me but the notion that
there is something that might be
conceptualized as gender although i
think that's a bad term is also i think
reasonable because
human beings vary substantially from
individual to individual in terms of
personality on the five cardinal
dimensions of personality and there are
plenty of men who have a typical
female personality structure and plenty
of females that have a typical male
personality structure and then if you
add to that variation in creativity
which which gives you a kind of fluidity
of identity it's sort of a hallmark of
creativity then the notion that there's
a gender that's separate from sex starts
to take on some validity but i like to
approach it from the personality
dimension i mean men and women overlap
quite a lot in their personality so
that's why yeah no i think that's
entirely correct i would say sex is
divided biological sex is divided in
mostly male and female
and
there is an in between category
but
sex is based on
on on
chromosomes on genitals on hormones
that's what sex is
um
gender
is divided better divided in masculine
and feminine than in male 1
so i would say gender is masculine and
feminine
and everything in between all sorts of
combinations are possible
and gender is a much more flexible
concept that was introduced
the origin of gender
is is john money the sexologist who
introduced the term
because um
he had noticed that there were people
who were born
with one sex but in the course of their
life felt they belong to another sex and
so he felt he needed to have a term for
that and and they only at the time they
only had negative labels for these
people like weird and queer and abnormal
and whatever
and he wanted to have a more scientific
and a friendlier label for them and
that's where why he came up with the
word gender he was also the first one to
to set up a gender clinic
so the word gender relates more to the
cultural side
how we expect men and women to behave um
the social norms that we have the
education that we give them and so
that's the gender side and the gender
side is obviously much more flexible and
and much more fluid so i want to i want
to ask you about that too because you
said that the gender side is more
socialized and you know i'm not i'm not
so sure about that
um i think this separation
i mean i'm not unsure about it either
because culture obviously matters but
you know a lot of the differences that
you see from individual to individual
are at least 60
biologically determined so variation so
if you're born let's say as a male with
a female temperament so you're high in
agreeableness empathy and you're low in
negative emotion because that's the
typical female pattern about 60 percent
of the variance in that is attributable
to genetic factors so we could have a
sex and gender split
as as the as the political types insist
that's also grounded in biological
differences without making a categorical
distinction you know say yeah so
absolutely
they always remain connected
the reason that we have genders and
they're to have a duality of gender
is because we have sexes
so people who say that gender is purely
in our heads is purely
a society product
that's an impossibility i think if we
were a cloning species
so we had no sexual reproduction
where we would all be identical no one
would have come up with the concept of
gender so the concept of gender is
related to sex
there is a certain independence between
the between them but they also remain
joined at some point and and you're
right
it is never purely cultural
uh justice and you show that you show
that in your book because and i want to
go into it in quite a bit of detail so
for example
let's start with this
toy preference and differences in
nurturance behavior and and so i'd like
you to lay that out and then we could
talk about that psychologically for a
bit yes
it's interesting if you look at um
the behavior of the young primates
and and children human children
you see a lot of similarity there and
and often people of course
think that the toy preferences are
socialized that we see um
but i think there's too much similarity
with what we see in other primates so uh
young
female primates they
they are very fond of infants they want
to hold infants as soon as there's a
newborn baby
and the mother arrives with it they want
to they surround her there's very few
males are interested in that but the
young females want to
get their hands on the on the on the
infant
and in
in nature we also know that they pick up
logs and rocks and chimpanzees do and
and the young females they carry them
around on their back on their belly
as if they have a doll if in captivity
you give them a doll like a teddy bear
they will walk around with it and take
care of it and be friendly with it
whereas young males they have a tendency
to um to take them apart basically
and look what's inside and so the the
females have this very strong urge to
hold infants and and
the same thing has been found in in
human children that girls are more
interested in infants than boys are and
if you look at the young males
the young males have a higher energy
level this is also true for boys versus
girls they have a higher energy level
and what they love to do is roughhousing
mock fighting that's what they do the
whole day basically they like to mock
fight
with each other sometimes with
adolescent males to just to test their
strengths on them and um
so rough and tumble play also in human
children much more typical of boys and
of girls and and
and the segregation that we see in the
playground between boys playing together
and girls playing together
probably comes to a large degree from
the fact that the girls don't like all
this rough housing that the boys are
doing that's not their type of play and
so they stay away from them because it's
too rough for them so i spent a lot of
time looking at the play literature in
children
so partly i worked with a team of
investigators at montreal who were
interested in the origin of anti-social
behavior and this is partly what gave me
a foray into your work by the way
so
uh the lead researcher there was richard
trombley who's done a lot of great work
on i know his work yeah you know his
work yeah trombly is great man and he
was on this podcast by the way and i
worked with him for
15 years something like that didn't he
work with fred's prayer who was also
there yeah
yeah yeah so so um he was interested in
the origins of anti-social behavior and
criminality
mostly and while we were together we
kept pushing back the origin
time in some sense of anti-social
behavior until the age of two and he had
put about a bunch of interventions in
place to try to modulate anti-social
behavior but it's very very persistent
once it's established very difficult to
to ameliorate and so
um
there's a subset of two-year-olds about
five percent of them of the males almost
all male who bite hit kick and steal at
the age of two now most two-year-olds
don't but a percentage do
and most of them are socialized by the
age of four
and so that becomes either in probably
integrated into their personality rather
than repressed so maybe they're more
disagreeable
from a personality perspective highly
probable they're more competitive
they're blunter but they get socialized
and and
one of the key questions is you know who
socializes them and my suspicions are in
many cases it's a father or a father
equivalent
in any case the ones who don't get
socialized
they
aren't popular with their peers
and
humans get socialized primarily by their
peers after age four so they get to be
little outcasts and then there are
bullies and then they're juvenile
delinquents and then they're criminals
that's where the life course persistent
criminals that's the population from
which they're derived and so then we
looked at what was socializing them
and the answer to that which i thought
was so cool and so great was play
both pretend play and bluff and tumble
play yeah and pancep has done lovely
work on rats with rough and tumble play
yeah that's a point that i make in my
book is that the play behavior of the of
the boys and of young male primates
it's partly developing fighting skills
so it's partly just like in the females
they're interested in infants is a
preparation for adult life when they
will have offspring and for the males
the play fighting is in the preparation
for adult life in which they will have a
lot of competition going
but another aspect very important is
that they learn how to control their
strengths
they learn how to be nice to others they
learn to release pressure once the other
cannot stand it
so if you look at an adult male gorilla
for example with his big fist
on a baby gorilla he could just there's
a little pressure he could kill it
because he's incredibly strong
but you know adult male gorillas they
play with infants and and they do very
well with them and that is because he
has learned over a lifetime to control
his physical strengths yes right and
that's that rough and tumble play is so
important for that because it's embodied
right so one of the things i because i
really got interested in rough and
tumble play as a primary source of
socialization of aggression is that
and and also more than that right
because it also underlies the spirit of
reciprocity i think which is manifested
in pure in its purest sense in the
spirit of play because play is something
that the participants have to engage in
voluntarily yeah and you have to
they have to enjoy it right
so this also relates very much to the
gender relationship is that uh because
we have a lot of trouble of course with
men abusing women
men need to learn about their strengths
need to learn how to control it need to
to learn when to hold back and when to
use it
and and play is an important factor in
that and so uh when i now hear i hear
sometimes from people who have children
that at schools there is less recess
time and there is less opportunity for
physical contact because the teachers
say that you shouldn't be touching it
my kids school the boys and the girls
were forbidden to even pick up snow
on the off chance that they would make a
snowball and so they just stopped the
rough and tumble play of the males 100
percent and pancetta showed if you
deprived male rats of plague juveniles
they started they would play
hyperactively when you gave them the
chance and that you could use
methylphenidate to suppress that oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
a bit rough
but the rough and tumble play is
absolutely essential it's not just for
developing fighting skills which is part
of it but it's also how males control
themselves how they because they become
physically stronger than females they
they need to have full control over
their body right and they well i think
they also learn i think through rough
and tumble play kids also learn
what hurts and what is what hurts them
really and so because when you rough and
tum i rough and tumble played with my
kids a lot i set up kind of a little
wrestling ring made out of two couches
pushed together and one of it and they
love it right they're so excited by it
but you tend to push the kids to their
physical limits right because you twist
their arms and you sort of toss them in
the air and and well you're engaged in
this dance that's an exploration of
physical limitation and so i think one
of the things that play does
and and pranks showed uh there was a
student of his tiffany fields who
massaged premature infants in in the
incubator it showed that she could
rapidly radically facilitate their
development i think play also regulates
emotion
because it because it's soothing and and
it it shows you it allows you to make a
clear distinction between
real threats and false threats and
between physical situations that
actually hurt and those that that don't
and that has to be done in an embodied
sense so the sort of funny thing that
that happened to me is that i
when i was a student i worked with two
young chimpanzees who
loved to play with me
so they were only five years old
but they were already much stronger than
i was
you know it develops much physically
much stronger than even though they're
smaller
that's physically stronger than that and
so uh i would rough and trouble play
with them
and it was
you know i would always lose because
they have four hands and they can put
you in a knot in a way that
is impossible for me to get out of and
each time i would protest i would say
and
let them know that this was they were
going too far with me
they would be very worried they would
come around and they would look at my
face and they would be looking very
worried
and and sort of like surprised that this
this big fellow was so weak in in their
opinion you know and then they would
slow down their play and they would be
very gentle for
10 minutes or so it would be very gentle
with me so they can calibrate it yeah
and that's how play goes also in in dogs
play play is a is constantly measuring
what is painful what is not painful and
of course the goal is to have fun that's
the right main goal so so um
that calibration is going on the whole
time yeah right right right well and
that's well so you know piaget
uh who wrote a great john psja wrote an
absolutely stellar book on the
development of of morality out of the
spirit of play it's a great book and
you know he showed
so he also and this is germaine to your
work he
he made a technical case that
any organization that's based on the
spill spirit of voluntary reciprocity
will over a reasonable period of time
compete any organization based on the
spirit of compulsion because
if you use force and compulsion you have
to waste energy and resources
on the compulsion plus you don't
optimally motivate and so that's another
pointer to an intrinsic ethic of
reciprocal cooperation and i think that
best so one of the things i've been
thinking about lately is the best
rejoinder to the sort of postmodern and
neo-marxist insistence that it's power
and dominance above all is that no it's
not is that's an aberration from the
spirit of play because if it's if a
society and any social interaction is
optimally structured then it moves out
of it moves into the domain of voluntary
play this is mutually enjoyable stays on
the side of positive emotion and it also
involves this continual mutual
collaboration which which children start
to seriously negotiate between the ages
of two and four
yeah yeah and so the
what you mentioned is that socialization
is mostly done by children by the peers
you know that's a very interesting
thought because
in my discussion of gender i noticed
that many people think that
socialization is a one-way street
the parents socialize their children
and i think parents overestimate their
influence on children i think children
socialize themselves to a large degree i
call it self-socialization
they look for adult
models
it can be the mother can be the father
it can be somebody else they look for
adult models can also be imaginary
models that they see on tv basically
well that's the purpose of fiction as
far as i could tell yeah fiction puts up
ritual models for emulation yeah and and
so the children socialize themselves and
then in addition you have all the peer
influences on them
and so i think parents totally
overestimate their effect on this yeah
our our research at montreal basically
indicated that the the proper so imagine
that the
the
the averaged
parent which would be sort of the
consequence of a monogamous relationship
right so
two half insane people unite and produce
one moderately sane person and then that
same person is a
analog of the general social environment
and then the purpose of that same person
on the socialization front is to
help the child manage his or her
behavior so that they become optimally
socially acceptable by the age of four
when their peers take over mm-hmm and so
that's that yeah that's how it seems to
be and then you know you talked about
this self-socialization you say well how
can kids self-socialize and part of the
answer to that is
if you don't socialize your children in
a manner they find
enjoyable let's say in the spirit of
play i know some discipline is necessary
but in the spirit of play the children
will vociferously and continually object
right they'll cry they they'll be
uncooperative they certainly won't be
enthusiastic and so there is a dynamic
dance there right from the beginning
that that the child and the i think this
is also why by the way you know there's
all these studies showing that
there's a fair genetic influence on
temperament and there's a pretty decent
influence of non-shared environment but
there's hardly any influence of shared
environment and i think the reason for
that isn't so much that parents are
irrelevant but that good parents
particularize the environment so much in
response to their child's temperament
that there isn't a lot of overlap yeah
yeah yeah and so in the other primates
we see the same thing we see that young
females
they uh imitate their mother more than
young males young males so for example a
recent study on orangutans in in the
forest found that
daughters eat exactly the same foods as
their moms
sons they have a more variety in their
diet
you know there's hundreds and hundreds
of plants around and fruits around so
they they learn their diet from others
and so the sun's they they learn it
mostly from males and and other
individuals that they see around there's
other studies on tool use for example
that
daughters copy exactly the tool
technology that our mom uses sons they
have they they're on their own with that
and they develop their own tool
technologies and so in in the primates
we see because they you know chimp is
adult when he's 16 so there's a very
long learning period
we see that they self-socialize by
emulating individuals of their sex
and that means also that the concept of
genders is applicable to them because
they are also culturally influenced
they're influenced by the behavior of
adults around them and that's why i use
the word gender also for the other
primates
okay so i want to read something to you
from your book and then i want to
discuss that for a second this is from
deborah bloom you you cite her
my son marcus passionately covets toy
weaponry
denied even so much as one lousy plastic
pistol by his gun intolerant mother he
has compensated by building armaments
out of everything from clay to kitchen
utensils i watched him charge after the
cat shooting shouting shoot him with a
toothbrush
and i found myself mentally throwing up
my hands now to me
that's kind of amusing but i didn't
really find it amusing i actually found
it really dark because
the the line of work that you're
pursuing which shows quite clearly as
does the personality literature on these
topics that these toy preferences and
behavioral differences are deeply
grounded in biology and they may also be
fostered culturally but fundamentally
it's the manifestation of an intrinsic
mode of being an
instinctual pattern and this woman this
author says
her you know
he's she's throwing up her hands because
she can't stop her son from being a boy
i don't find that a music i find that
actually quite horrifying and you know
the idea yeah that has to do with the
the desire of many parents to influence
their children and to make them sort of
gender neutral and to have boys play
with dolls and girls play with trucks
and of course there are a few who will
do that um
but um they they're trying to go against
what whatever the tendencies are and
they punish and they punish those
tendencies at least implicitly and now
you know if male ambition serves power
and oppression then you can understand
why early manifestations of that might
be worth punishing especially if that
was culturally
a cultural consequence but if the
fundamental male drive is something like
reciprocity and competence and say aim
because i think that's relevant to the
use of weapons then the punishing of
that the viewing it as only serving
power and oppression instead of
competence and reciprocity that's an
awful thing and i think and i'd like to
know what you think about this but you
know boys are not doing that well in
school and they're all the way through
kindergarten through university they're
dropping out and they're also
increasingly an interesting less
interested in sexual activity of all
sorts even masturbation
and i think that it's a consequence of
of this attitude it's like they're
punished for a male typical pattern of
behavior that's improperly associated
with dominance right from day one so
yeah boys
boys are more often kicked out of school
um
that's a that's a big problem and and
that has probably to do with their
tendency of roughhousing and and mock
fighting which they do all the time
and yeah
the way i look at that is that that's a
primate pattern all the male primates
like to do that mock fighting
and we at our schools in the west we
have decided to stop that and to to say
you shouldn't be touching yeah you know
i worked with this guy named uh
dan always and he wrote a great book
called bullying what it is and what we
can do about a very straightforward guy
kind of like a 50s engineer and he
reduced the bullying incidents and
associated alcoholism and criminality in
scandinavia the whole in a number of
countries by 50 percent
and he went into schools he was really
careful because he defined bullying very
particularly he said he didn't associate
it with
rough and tumble play for example
because he actually had a clue
he said you know you mentioned earlier
that the uh reciprocal male alpha who's
competent breaks up
unfair fights okay so that's what always
did he went into schools and he said
look
you can intervene in an incident of
aggression when there's a clear
and inequitable power balance so if a 12
year old is beating up an eight year old
or if two 10 year olds are picking on a
10 year old and then he talked to kids
you can go
tattle to a teacher which is otherwise
forbidden
as all children know and most adults
should remember
you can it's your ethical responsibility
to inform a person in authority if you
see violence with power imbalance and
then he taught the teachers and the
parents the same thing this very narrow
narrow focus on a very specific form of
aggressive behavior that wasn't play
and no one's paying any attention to it
in north america like even though it's a
stunning body of research and the only
body of research i know that shows a
positive effect of the attempts to
socially ameliorate anti-social behavior
but instead we get this over reaction
that includes all elements of play
rough and tumble play in particular and
it's also why boys are medicated if
pancep
they manifest this boisterous
rough and humble play desire and it's
disruptive in classrooms and that
the best trip quick trip out of that is
an amphetamine which suppresses play
behavior that's what it does technically
and biochemically yeah it makes me think
of um i did a lot of studies of
reconciliation behavior so so what
happens after a fight who reconciles
with whom and so on
and actually males are quite good males
are good at fighting but also also good
at reconciling after fights
and in those studies
of reconciliation behavior there were
some developmental psychologists who
started looking at children we did the
studies on the primates who kissed and
embrace after a fight or sometimes have
sex after fights things like that
but they did studies in in human
cultures and what they found is that
japanese children
reconcile a lot more than western
children after fights and are much
better at conflict resolution
and the reason they gave this is not my
study but the reason they gave is that
in japan the teachers don't break up
fights
like if well of course accepted they're
killing each other but right right they
they usually don't break up fights
they let the kids fight
and if they think it needs to be
interrupted or
calmed down they send another child an
older child they sent an other child to
mediate between them
so that's so smart because otherwise too
you know the kid that's getting beat up
is now
vilified because a teacher had to
intervene on his behalf so now he was a
bully victim to begin with let's say and
now he can't even stand up for himself
and a teacher has to come to his aid
it's a terrible status defeat for him so
so the in the primates of course there
is a lot of reconciliation there's also
mediation and reconciliation so older
females who bring parties together
sometimes
um but
they all learn in their lifetime how to
fight and how to reconcile after fights
and i'm from a family of six boys i i
maybe my interest in conflict resolution
was partly because as a boy in a boy
family you learn how to do these yeah
well you know okay so
one of the things that psychologists
like jonathan height has have commented
on is this
culture of fragility that we've produced
and emotional overreaction and i think
the comment you just made all those are
germane to that because we don't know
how many
siblings or peers a child needs to be
exposed to in order to become resilient
and learn to engage in reconciliation so
imagine the typical human family
wouldn't have had one child
would have had multiple so they'd have
to be strategizing and jockeying for
attention in a way that didn't cause
undue tyranny and aggression so first of
all we have lots of single child
families or two child families but
single often and then also to much older
parents
and so if if the children are actually
being socialized in large part let's say
by their siblings in in a more
naturalistic human community part of the
reason for this emergent fragility could
well be that they haven't had to engage
in say that japanese style of conflict
that isn't mediated by parents and they
haven't learned to
to reconcile i i want to point out to
the viewers and listeners too that dr
dual's work on reconciliation is also of
groundbreaking importance as far as i'm
concerned because
he put the other
what the other shoe dropped with the
work on reconciliation because you can
think well conflict is a terrible thing
aggression is a terrible thing and the
aggressive males are power hungry and
demonic and dominant but you showed very
clearly that the sophisticated males are
experts at reconciliation and sometimes
that expertise even exceeds that of the
females
and all of that needs to be learned
so you need to provide learning
opportunities and if it's not in a
family if the family has just one or two
children
then you need to bring children together
somehow in your neighborhood or
in a school or you need to give them the
opportunity to learn these things and i
think
we are very good at removing these
opportunities and that's partly or
forbidding them even yeah there's partly
a fear of competition so for example
um
i've read in the psych in the psychology
literature that
they say that women have very good
friendships wonderful friendships deep
friendships and so on but man men are
too competitive men are hierarchical and
competitive
yeah and that's what they say even
though many men have friends and and
enjoy the company of other men but
i think they're confusing competition
between man this friendship is it's like
you can only don't know how to integrate
i mean men male friendships that are
optimized are
competitive in in the extreme often
often on the basis of humor
yeah so so they they confuse um
they think it's either competitive or
friends
and the combination of the two they
cannot see
and and i think uh for man for sure that
combination exists and men can be rivals
and competitors and but but half an hour
later they're laughing with each other
let me tell you a funny story
there was once a um a
swimming trainer in the netherlands
who uh trained girls for swimming
swimming competition
and she switched to boys and then i saw
this interview with her in the newspaper
why did she switch to boys and she said
well if the girls on the team have a
fight that starts in the early season
they will have that fight going for the
whole season it will not stop if the if
the boys have a fight
they drink in the evening they drink a
beer and the next day they don't even
remember the fight anymore she says and
yeah or or they or
they have a fight
and then they reconcile and the fight is
over so okay so i want to use that as a
segue into something else you wrote so
we can talk about it so i want to read
something again that from different from
the introduction
and uh i don't know if you agreed with
this or if you were just if you were
saying it as a summary of someone else's
thought but you said
it's easy to see
why male and female patterns of
aggression are valued so differently
only the first
creates trouble in societies and so
so let me riff on that for a sec and
then turn it over to you so
i think this observation you made about
the swim teams is extremely interesting
because
we studied male pattern aggressive
behavior which tends to involve physical
violence and female pattern aggressive
behavior in humans and what the females
do is gossip back bite and destroy
reputations
and the female antisocial types are
really really good at that and they're
vicious and the thing that
differentiates those right now so in
such a cardinal manner in my estimation
is that
female aggression scales on the internet
and male aggression does not
and so you know we we know that
the online world is vicious in a very
particular way and i think a big part of
it is that it actually can't be settled
so part of the reason that women have
difficulty
in conflict is because men can resort to
fighting
and that will produce an alteration in
the it'll produce a cessation of the
conflict in a very real sense one way or
another right but when women are
embroiled in a conflict well they can't
fight physically
and
and so they do get caught in this
conundrum so one of the problems that
our society really
wrestles with at the moment is that
it's very difficult to control
untrammeled female pattern aggression
and so i think it is causing a
tremendous amount of trouble and that
that reputation damaging
that
a huge you just see that constantly on
social media platforms and so i don't
know if that was your thought or if it
was a thought that you were summarizing
but i'm kind of curious about your
thoughts about that
yeah so um
i make a distinction in my book between
two ways of keeping the peace
one is peace making the other one is
peacekeeping
the males in chimpanzees the males are
very good at peacemaking they have a
fight and then they get together they
kiss and embrace and then they groom
each other
and and they cycle through this all the
time it's very very easy process for
them
and they have more fights than females
and i think what the females do the
females reconcile less when they have a
fight less often than the males
because they have more trouble with that
i think
and what the females do is stay away
from your rivals stay away from fights
stay away from individuals that you're
likely to will have i call that
peacekeeping
is that they suppress aggression and
they stay away from themselves all right
so let's look at that in the in the
human case so the one of the biological
temperamental differences that you see
between men and women is that women are
higher in negative emotion that starts
in puberty because boys and girls are
the same and it doesn't change
throughout the life course and women are
more agreeable
and so that combination so agreeable
people are
conflict avoidant
now agreeableness is empathy and that's
supposed to be a cardinal virtue but the
downside of agreeableness and empathy is
conflict avoidance
and so and and you if you add conflict
avoidance is emotionally taxing
so so i think it's also practically a
problem because it means that if someone
pushes on you that you have to negotiate
with you have to avoid and or you won't
push back and what the hell are you
going to do on the negotiating front if
that's the case stay at your workplace
you can't avoid your boss
but the interesting thing is that
both strategies are actually quite
successful
we did a study of human behavior in the
hospitals we looked at operating rooms
and we looked at how how well men and
women work together
and female cooperation is really highly
developed
so female teams not all female teams but
but females on the team
works very well and so i think
both
sexes have a good strategy one isn't to
suppress conflict the other one is to
reconcile very easily so they're both
good strategies and they're both quite
effective but they're totally different
okay so let me let me push you on that
just for a sec then so let's take an
optimal
female cooperating group
see the conundrum i think they run into
and i think this is the conundrum of
compassion in general is that that's
just fine until you throw a predator in
and so a group like that that's actually
made out of pure cooperators can work
just fine but if you throw in a woman
who has antisocial personality which
would be manifested says borderline
personality disorder which looks like
the clinical equivalent of asp in
females or if you throw in a real
predator the co-op like what if the
cooperators can't avoid and they can't
oppose
all they have left is to fall victim to
the predator and that's why i think that
met women are in this weird evolutionary
conundrum because they have to find men
who are
disagreeable enough to stave off the
real predators
but agreeable enough to
be generous with their productive
competence right and so it's this knife
edge you know because a little too far
in either direction is not good so is
there a flaw in my reasoning there is
with regards to the
to the to the achilles heel let's say of
of female cooperative groups no i i
think it is true that that we have
always underestimated female
competitiveness
so
so um you know
in in the psychological literature
males were always called hierarchical
and competitive
and not females
and now we know that that you know
there's plenty of female competition and
there's plenty of female hierarchies
actually the word packing order comes
from hence not from roosters and and in
the animal kingdom lots of females have
hierarchies have alpha females and so on
so i think it's important to point out
always that
female competition is maybe less
physical but it's not it's not absent
well it's probably also not competition
about exactly the same things well in
your work on animal cognition you use
this term umvelt which is like the
implicit
motivational environment in some sense
that an animal might inhabit and i'd
like to talk about that in a bit but
men and women don't compete within their
own sexes for status in the same way
and so it's easy for men to look at
women and think well they're not that
competitive it's well they're not
engaged in rough and tumble player or
violent confrontation
but that doesn't mean that the
competition isn't there it's just that
and it also may be that men aren't
subtle enough in some sense to see it
now let me let me tell you a funny story
on that this this was a scientist a
woman scientist in finland who studied
children at play
in in the in the playground and she said
if you watch these children at the end
of the day you say that the boys had
five times as many or six times as many
fights as the girls
and that's just from watching them
if she asked the kids at the end of the
day did you have a fight today
the boys and girls had equal numbers
which means that the girl fights are
just not visible she and she said
if a girl walks up to another girl and
that girl turns around and walks away
they consider that a fight right well
that's that that's very interesting but
of course boys will boys will not
consider that a fight
more needs to happen yeah no the boys
are not boys are not maybe even astute
enough in some sense to notice that yeah
you know the the thing that the thing an
anti-social girl will do
is she'll like a an unfamiliar girl or
even a familiar girl will approach a
play group that's already in formation
say and the the alpha female of the play
group will say we don't have to play
with you
and then and that's devastating right
because it's a real like cardinal
inclusion but there's no physical
aggression associated
and the girl who's rejected will walk
away crushed because she's been put down
as unacceptable socially yeah and that
all can happen
especially if the girl bully is
sophisticated you know because then an
adult can come in there and and call her
on it and she'll say oh well she's just
over sensitive i didn't really mean that
at all and and with a perfect facade of
angelic innocence as well which is the
anti-social female types
these differences are so interesting
these these sex differences that we see
in human behavior but they're not well
documented so recently i received a
handbook on i think it's developmental
psychology or something like that and i
looked for gender in there because i was
writing on gender
and there was almost nothing on gender
so the play differences between boys and
girls were not mentioned but also the
the conflict differences that you now
mentioned were not mentioned it's as if
the psychologists have decided that
that's a too
too sensitive as a topic to get into the
sex differences of i think part of it is
is that they actually
don't like the facts so for example
when i've been looking at personality
differences between men and women and we
did some of the cardinal work on that
with the big five uh aspect scale
so the truth of the matter is is that
temperamental differences between men
and women as so gender differences as
measured by personality scales which is
the right way to measure it
they maximize in scandinavia so the more
egalitarian the country the bigger the
gender differences which is exactly the
opposite of what the social
constructionists would have predicted
now some gender differences decrease so
men and women are more likely to be in
the workplace now than 40 years ago but
if you make an egalitarian society you
actually maximize gender differences
which is no one expected that and it
just flies in the face of this so sort
of margaret mead early margaret mead
like social constructionism and then you
add to that a couple so that accounts
that plus the difference in interest
which is relevant to your work so girls
are reliably more interested in people
and boys reliably more interested in
things so that's say dolls and cars or
toy cars and that also maximizes in the
scandinavian countries it's one standard
deviation the difference it's the
biggest personality difference between
men and women that we know and it
accounts for a huge
um amount of the variance in
occupational choice like between say
engineering and nursing which would be
the cardinal examples and so the
psychologists look at that and they
think oh my god that isn't how we want
it to be and so they don't talk about
your work and they don't talk about toy
preference differences and they don't
talk about temperamental differences
it's all like shunted under the carpet
so so you mentioned margaret mead who's
often
mentioned in the context of cultural
construction of of gender differences
but i reread her book her book male and
female
and she has a whole section in there
about what she calls universal
differences between men and women
so she
and and in in a later edition of her
book she said if she had to write it
today this was in the 1960s her book was
i think published in the 50s she said if
i see if i would write it today i would
bring in more biology the biology of the
differences between men and women and so
one of the differences that she mentions
is that
men always want to accomplish something
they want to be better at something than
other men or women
they feel that's that's their goal in
life so to speak uh and she mentioned
that as a universal thing in man she
mentions also of course
the child-bearing capacities of of women
and the interest in in children of women
and and the interest of women in the
well-being of others and of themselves
and and their family and so she mentions
in that chapter
quite a few things that i think are uh
universal uh sex differences well let's
see
she was more she was more open-minded i
would say than than than her followers
in that regard yeah well so this this
desire to be better at something so
let's take that apart a bit in light of
our discussion
if you're cynical about that you can say
well that desire to be better at
something is nothing but a manifestation
of that power and dominance drive right
and so it's to be disc competitive urges
to be discouraged because it's a
zero-sum game and one person always
gains at the expense of another but if
you look at the even the animal
literature in a sophisticated way you
think wait a minute
competence is associated with
hierarchical status it's very
sophisticated it's a competition for
competence even among animals and even
more so among human beings and so that
ambition that young boys manifest is
can easily be uh manifested in the
service of social goods and furthermore
and this is the thing that's so awful
about it for me is that that's actually
the primary thing that male humans have
to offer females which is well look of
course i want to be better at something
because i want to be differentiated
economically and and to be paid for
something you have to be better at it
than others otherwise no one will pay
you they'll pay someone else and so what
i see happening to boys in our culture
and i've seen this with thousands of
people is that their ambition is being
quelled because it's associated
unthinkingly with power and that
undermines their entire commitment to
the social and the sexual and
interpersonal enterprise
[Music]
yeah i think um there is a there is a
bit of suppression of those tendencies
yeah so okay so maybe
maybe we could move too if you don't
mind to the
animal cognitive front you talked about
cognitive ethology and uh
and
i'd like to get your thoughts on that
too you wrote a book
whose title i don't remember precisely
but it's something like are we smart
enough to know how smart animals are
it's yes i guess exactly that's exactly
that's so good i got it right so let's
let's walk through that a bit and i
would like if you would as well
this point that
our perceptions
and our thoughts are shaped by our
morphology
in some fundamental way you make a nice
example of gibbons for example and the
fact that octopi and elephants and
primates can be intelligent in a
particular way because they have
manipulable appendages unlike say
so let me give give an example um
how we mismeasured the animals
so
elephants there was the question do
elephants use tools
so what people did is they take an
elephant at the zoo
they put some food outside of the cage
you give the elephant sticks
and the elephant doesn't do anything
with the sticks
if you do the same experiment with the
chimp of course he takes the stick and
reaches the food and brings it close to
him and then eats the food so the chimp
will use the stick to to get the food
the elephant didn't do that and the
conclusion of that study was that
elephants are not too useless
then a couple of years later another
research team they did a smart thing
they hung some food very high
so that the elephant couldn't reach it
and they put in his enclosure a bunch of
boxes wooden boxes
and what the elephant did is he would
grab a box bring it close to under the
foot put it under the food and then
stand on top of the box and reach the
food
so he was using a tool clearly
the conclusion of that research team was
that an elephant the trunk we think it's
like a hand but the trunk is also a nose
of course and if the trunk reaches for
food it needs to close itself
when it grabs the food and the elephant
was not ready to close his nose while he
was grabbing food
but if he could stand on boxes that
would that would work for him
and so the we need to think in terms of
the animal and its physical features
and and that
a trunk is not an arm it's not the same
thing we need to start thinking like the
animals and then we can solve a lot of
these problems of their intelligence our
appendages in some sense are primary
tools
and so if you don't give an animal a
problem that it can solve with its
primary set of tools it's obviously not
going to be able to solve it and so that
also
brings us into the issue of embodied
perception you know because i i read a
great book called uh ecological approach
to visual perception which jj gibson
which is man that's a classic book
something brilliant and
you know he his
premise fundamentally is that
we see
with our hands in some real sense is
that when we look at the world we
basically construe it as a set of
grippable objects now it's more complex
because we see walkable surfaces and
climbable
you know what would you call climbable
slopes and so forth so it's not just
hands but that our eyes function to map
our hands onto the world yeah
i think it's
it's a brilliant book and that's why we
understand a chimpanzee much better than
an elephant or a dolphin yeah a
chimpanzee has hands and has binocular
vision so we we are completely in tune
with the chimpanzee and not in june with
an elephant or a giraffe or whatever it
is yeah right and and that that
understanding is a consequence not so
much of of mutual misunderstanding so to
speak it's much more profound than that
it's because our cognitive and
perceptual architectures actually
scaffolded off our morphology
if the morphology is different enough we
wouldn't be able to understand the
animal even if we could communicate
because none of the presuppositions
would be the same
i think eo wilson i wasn't wilson who
said um
if we could speak with a lion we'd have
nothing to say to him something like
that or he might have said it about ants
i think it was wittgenstein you know
okay
okay i know a number of people have made
similar comments but well you also
detail out uh
the developing understanding of the
given hand and species specific face
identification
yeah so the gibbon hand is interesting
because the gibbon has no almost no
thumb so it's more like a hook he hangs
by the hand
and and so when they tested tool used on
the given the gibbons were not using
tools at all they never did anything
until a smart investigator lifted the
tools up a little because they give the
gibbon cannot pick up something from the
ground and
since the gibbon doesn't live in the on
the ground he lives in up in the trees
it doesn't matter for the gibbon that he
cannot do that but in the experimental
situations
they couldn't pick up the tools so yeah
you always have to test animals and that
becomes ever more
complex for example the elephant
has a hundred times better smell
olfaction than the dog the dog probably
and the dog probably a hundred times
better than us
so you can imagine the elephant you need
to test them probably on olfaction so
recently right recently josh plotnik a
former student of mine he did an
experiment with elephants in thailand
where he would give them
two buckets
in one bucket he would beat sunflower
seeds and the other one was empty and
then the elephant of course was his
trunk would he could not look into it
but with the trunk would smell and would
pick the the bucket with the sunflower
seeds then he started to vary the
quantities and he found
that elephants can distinguish a bucket
with
seats
from a bucket with a 100 seats
so they can count with their nose so to
speak
they're so sensitive no animal can do
that i think but the elephant can do
that so they can estimate quantity
people fact early yeah yeah yeah wow wow
and has it has the limits of that
discrimination being tested
yeah well i think if you look at that
paper that he has been testing by making
the differences smaller and smaller yeah
oh that's really something well yeah we
have no idea how an animal most animals
brains are are arranged around old
fashioned not vision we're really weird
in that regard it's like us and birds of
prey you know and maybe some close
primate relatives that's it the rest of
the animal kingdom it's almost all smell
and we can hardly even imagine what a
world like that is like so the brain
business is interesting because at some
point five years six years ago people
said we should not look at brain size
not even a brain size relative to the
body we should just count the number of
neurons
and
and that will give us an index of the
intelligence of an animal and and of
course everyone was convinced at that
time that humans have the most neurons
we have 85 billion neurons or something
like that
until
a couple of years later it was found
that the elephant has three times more
neurons than the human
and and then that theory was abandoned
because humans need to stay on top yeah
well you know we radically underestimate
the the relationship between
intelligence and morphology you know i
thought about this in particular with
regards to dolphins who have quite a
remarkably large brain and a large brain
in relation to their body size and say
well dolphins are intelligent it's like
well it's possible that they're
intelligent in some way we don't really
understand but they don't have hands
and so they can't build anything and
i would our prefrontal cortex emerged in
large part out of the motor cortex
across the course of evolution and it
looks like what we do with our
prefrontal cortex is primarily map out
action and manipulation before
implementing it and so again we think of
the world as a place we can grip and
move and when we think about problem
solving cognitively we're really looking
at
elaborations of what we do with our
hands so it's not obvious at all what
dolphins do if they think because what
can they do with it that's even
reflected in our language can can you
grasp the problem right exactly
exactly that yeah can you get a grip on
it you know can you get a handle on it
absolutely can you handle that that's
all that's all questions about
competence
and so yeah well so so if you if you
look at the animal kingdom we judge
animals by our standards we are good at
language and we're good at tool use
and that's our standards
but if you look at for example
echolocation by bats it's a very complex
cognitive skill ask any engineer who who
designs radar system for for airplanes
how complex that is you're a moving
object and you need to calculate and you
recalculate and so on and so
echolocation is a very complex skill and
you can dark this room make it
completely dark and release an insect
and the bat can catch the insect it's
just incredible that they can do that
but we're not impressed by it we're not
impressed by the bad because we don't do
these things we're not echolocators and
so
bad
intelligence is not on our radar so to
speak
uh we we always go for language until we
use well and dolphins echo locate too
so so that could be a huge part of what
their cognitive process is devoted
towards and god only know what they're
doing linguistically so let's locate
let's talk about
um
one of the things i liked about
the your book on animal uh
cognition was because i've thought this
for a long time especially in
relationship to rat studies so there's
this idea that was drummed into my head
as an undergraduate is that you
shouldn't anthropomorphize animals
and then as i got to be a more
sophisticated
viewer of the animal literature i
thought no no no that's exactly
backwards what you should do is presume
continuity of all function unless
there's compelling reason to not and so
that may be interested in the issue of
animal consciousness
because conscious and so you touch on
consciousness in that book and so
when when
first so i'd like to ask you
what do you make of consciousness like
how would you define it and how far down
the animal chain i'll tell you a story
about a wasp
because i've watched wasps and those
bloody things man those things are
sophisticated
let me say one thing about
anthropomorphism okay okay
we need to respect
homologies homologies are
similarities between species that come
from a common ancestor so my hand
is homologous with the hand of a
chimpanzee
and so
what the chimpanzee has we don't call a
paw or a claw or no we call it a hand
because we use the same terminology for
homologous traits the same is true for
behavior if i laugh
my laughing expression is very similar
to that of a chimpanzee who is being
tickled
we need to both call it laugh when i was
younger people would say why don't you
call it vocalized panting
they wanted us to get away from them
anthropomorphism but i think
anthropomorphism is useful especially
for species that have homologues yeah
yeah right well that's where it should
be the assumption rather than the
exception yeah yeah so and pancept
showed that rats laugh too when you
tickle them they just do it
ultrasonically so that homology homology
is extremely deep okay so this wasp
it was buzzing around my head and i
nailed it with my hand and hard you know
i kind of snapped at it and so that's a
hell of a fast gesture that
forward movement back and so i nailed
the wasp with my finger and i knocked it
probably 15 feet which is a hell of a
g-force blow for an insect and that
bloody thing righted itself an inch from
the ground and dove directly at my face
and i thought oh my god like i don't and
then so i i watched that and i thought
wow that's something man that to do that
is something then i read also about
these wolf spiders who are predatory and
if they if they're on a plant here and
they see a prey animal or insect over
here they will walk down the plant
across the ground and jump on it from
behind it's like okay okay that's a
spider and it has
like no brain and yet that is so
unbelievably complicated navigation of
unfamiliar territory planning
yes it certainly does but i mean
neuronal neuronal uh number is very low
but i think are they are wasps conscious
are spiders conscious it's like
and you can take you know if you take
the whole cortex a neo the cortex and
the limbic system off a cat and you
leave it with nothing but its
hypothalamus and its spinal cord
that cat is hyper exploratory
and that's bloody weird right you take
the whole brain off a cat except for
like two percent and it doesn't just lay
there and do nothing what it does
instead is engage in almost all its
normal activities but it can't remember
anything so it's hyper curious
and so so let me let me give you my take
on consciousness because no one has a
good definition of it so
and if we have no definition how am i
going to measure it
but um
there are certain things that we humans
cannot do without being conscious
so for example you cannot plan a party
for tomorrow
without thinking about what you should
buy what kind of music you're gonna have
which friends you're gonna invite what
time it's gonna start
you have to be conscious of the process
before you you organize your party
now
we have evidence we have very good
evidence nowadays of planning in animals
so for example chimpanzees in the wild
they will pick up tools
and they gonna walk two miles with these
tools and then they're gonna use them on
a termite hill or whatever which means
that
20 minutes before
they started the activity they were
already planning the activity and so we
also have experiments now they have all
sorts of experiments where you you can
give tools to animals that they can use
only the next day so to speak so so
we have good evidence for planning now
in animals now if we if we cannot plan
if we cannot plan without being
conscious
it would be unlikely that these animals
can plan without being conscious because
of course the process is going to be
very similar to what we do okay so i
talked to dr roger penrose about
consciousness
and he believes it's non-computational
and non-algorithmic and the reason he
believes that in part is because the
horizon of the future
differs unpredictably from the past
that's the problem of induction and so
he thinks that consciousness is a tool
that we use to solve the problem of true
unpredictability and so your association
of consciousness with future planning
seems to me both dead on and in keeping
with that idea and so
so
so then
okay how far down the chained chain of
of of of animal existence do you think
that consciousness extends so
consciousness is i think a subcategory
the bigger category that we use usually
is sentience
you you must have heard about sentience
is the the ability to experience
positive positive or negative
experiences
and sentence probably goes back all the
way to insects
and and we use that emotional sentience
as well because it's associated with
approach and avoidance right so it's
really old yeah so maybe as soon as you
get a nervous system that can represent
embodied movement you get something akin
to the emotions of approach and
avoidance and then maybe something akin
to sentience at that point yeah
sentience for the longest time people
debated do fish feel pain which was a
sentience question do fish feel pain and
then experimentals they found that if
you shock fish or crabs
you know in a laboratory you bring them
in a situation where they can hide
themselves in in crevices and you shock
them in these places they're gonna avoid
the places where they were shocked right
so they have anxiety too then because
that avoidance is anxiety so they have
pain in that and they can abstract from
that so they have pain and they remember
the pain and they changed their behavior
as a result of that and so that was used
as a conclusion to conclude that these
animals have uh have sentience because
they they have experiences so sentence
is the bigger issue
also a more morally a very important
issue of course do animals have
sentience
and
consciousness
i i never know exactly what it is
because philosophers talk a lot about
consciousness but they never tell me how
to how to measure it well you said that
you know you you associated sentience
with the capacity to experience and then
i think well
there's no difference between the
capacity to experience and experience
and there's actually no difference
between experience and being because
it's very very difficult to understand
being itself in the absence of any
experience of being i mean what is it
that
there's not even nothing
right because nothing is
only a concept that's something that's
capable of apprehending something could
ever come up with so i don't see
consciousness and being as being
separable concepts in some sense and
okay okay so you chase that all the way
down to to insects
okay yeah so so
sentence new is now is recognized also
in invertebrates
and and there used to be a debate about
fish but i think that debate has been
settled well it certainly seems to be
the case for octopu octopi those things
are so so smart and so flexible in their
behavior that it's just it's beyond did
you see my octopus teacher yeah yeah
yeah
their capacity to mimic and camouflage
is just
to see that octopus aggregate all those
shells and turn itself into a rock i
mean especially given they have what
about a three-year life span
so the octa the octopus is interesting
that that movie the octopus teacher many
people were very moved by the octopus
embracing the the person you know who
approached
octopi are not particularly social as
you say they live maybe one year maybe
two years
they're very solitary creatures i don't
think they have love for each other or
the capacity to love a human but maybe
that octopus was very curious and and
maybe
maybe the octopus also felt safe in the
presence of a human because these humans
kept predators away i'm sure
so it was it was maybe a good situation
for the octopus to be in yeah and
curiosity could easily be uh the reason
because the octopus is so damn smart it
probably has some excess cognitive
capacity like yeah but but people then
often project yeah they would feel they
think the octopus is loving the human
i'm not sure about the loving i think i
think anything that isn't cuddly
is probably a little low on the love end
of things you know
so so
okay so so let's talk about
self-consciousness then because that's
that's the consciousness that's a
sentence that involves at least a
reflexive distinction between self and
and other broadly speaking and i've been
interested in but also skeptical of the
animal self-conscious experiments
because mirror recognition isn't nothing
but humans have an unbelievably
elaborated
self-consciousness i mean we're fully
aware of our span of life we know we're
gonna die we we can really
distinctly apprehend the future and we
have a really complex
explicit model of ourselves
and animals well that many animals can
recognize themselves in the mirror and
that's not nothing but it's certainly
no it's not there's not many animals
there's a few
there's only a few who do that
but we but we do have evidence in
chimpanzees and in in orangutans
that they embellish themselves in front
of the mirror so so the
observations they are mostly anecdotal
of of apes in captivity who put
something on their head and then look in
the mirror or or in in human context
they may put lipstick in and put look at
themselves in the mirror so so if you
embellish yourself and then look in the
mirror and it's sort of interesting uh
addition additional definitely because
yeah well it also sees that you view
yourself as a modifiable entity
in the eyes of others in all likelihood
yeah so we also have evidence from
behavior
that female apes female chimpanzees and
female bonobos they do more
self-adornment and self-embellishment
than the males so the females they will
hang things around themselves put things
on the head walk around with them uh
much more so than the males the males
also
use um
tools to enhance themselves but that's
more to be more intimidating right like
beating on our beating on a banging or
something yeah banging these things or
whatever when my daughter was young i
watched my kids quite closely when they
were little and there was a variety of
differences in them on the sex
difference front my son was much more
disagreeable and tough-minded than my
daughter for example and but i also saw
remarkably early in my daughter this
instinct for self-adornment now my wife
doesn't wear much jewelry or much makeup
she's kind of a minimalist in both
regards and so she didn't even have much
of a jewelry collection but my daughter
was really entranced by jewelry and
makeup
from as as long as far back as i could
remember and i thought well maybe that's
a
socialized difference but i can't see
how because
we did she didn't have makeup dolls it
wasn't part of what she was being fed
she didn't watch tv and so but she was
she was really really interested in
jewelry and endorment and i think that's
that's actually been a stable part of
her character because as an adult
she's been much more interested in
self-adornment than my wife was and it
wasn't obvious to me at all that she
learned that and i thought well that
that so
so in the in the apes that's all is that
a super stimulus thing like the stick
sticklebacks
it's it's more a female thing and i
think it in the apes of course the
females have a genital swelling
which fortunately i think humans should
be happy that we don't have that but
they have this
when they are fertile their genitals
swell up and i think the female apes
that's an adornment for sure and they
add to it they may add to it now we know
from human women
that in the time of ovulation
they adorn themselves more so our
studies on that is that women dress
differently every time of ovulation and
they expose more skin
and they uh
fancier clothes on usually at that time
that's also when they prefer
the same photos of men with a square jaw
than a narrower jaw
at the peak of ovulation all of this is
unconsciously because
in in that study they what they did is
they photographed women in the regular
clothes and then they asked them about
their menstrual cycle and that's how
they figured out how they were dressed
relative to the site right and that
would manifest itself in that oomvelt
which would be something like i really
feel like dressing up today
and there'd be no and that's a
spontaneous motivation that's drifting
up from hormonal influence
and and unconscious in that sense and
tuning by hormones tuning of perception
and emotion by hormonal influence so to
me it's always very interesting the
things that we do unconsciously and that
we we're not really aware of so there
was a study for example
looking at handshakes
and i think it was an israeli study
man shaking hands of men men shaking
hands of women and the other way around
and what they found is that
they people bring their hand to their
nose to close so they touch their face
they bring their hand close to their
nose when they have shaken hands with
same-sex partners
not really not that right eh not with
the opposite sex and they think it has
to do with testing anxiety or testing uh
dominance or testing right
well god only knows what sort of
information we're picking up on the old
factory front like a lot of that could
be unconscious i i mean i know for
example that uh
if you
give women
t-shirts laundry t-shirts have been worn
one day by men and you ask them to rate
the older preference the women prefer
symmetrical the t-shirts that
symmetrical men wore
so and that's obviously not in any sense
a conscious olfactory preference for
like the concept of symmetry it's just
built right into the old faction so
we've seen now during the covet crisis
that now that we're coming out of the
crisis everyone is very happy that that
we have physical interaction with others
and i think one of the things we have
missed is probably smell so you can you
can talk with your grandparents uh
over zoom but that's not the same as
visiting them and seeing them and
smelling them i once yeah there's a deep
sense of familiarity and memory that's
associated with that you know my wife
when my wife's mother died
my wife took one of her scarves and she
kept it in little jar and she now and
then she'd take it out and she could she
could detect these the the uh the smell
of her mother on that and then about
five years later she said i can't smell
my mother on this anymore and she just
got rid of it but that was a
you know that smell is so evocative
right and it can produce a kind of a
a longing and also a sense of deep
comfort
yeah yeah and but it is also you know i
was once on a flight before kovit
on a flight to tokyo i was sitting next
to a businessman and uh and he was going
to tokyo for a meeting of a couple of
hours and then he would fly back and i
said
you really feel that you need to fly to
tokyo for that you could do this
virtually
he said no no
it's a multi-million dollar deal and i
want to see these people i want to smell
these people i want to see them up close
he he felt that this all this bodily
interaction was awfully important to him
and and that is how we are and we we we
have remained primates in that regard
and the olfaction is largely unconscious
we we can we don't even have words for
it we cannot even express what's
happening but it's largely unconscious
but it's extremely important to us
yeah well we yeah
that's the problem with virtualizing the
world to some degree is we don't know
well like we talked about earlier
does me does female pattern antisocial
behavior scale on social media and if
the answer to that is yes it's like well
that's revolutionary because it's never
scaled before
and so we have no idea what these
virtual virtual environments are doing
to us by interfering in unexpected ways
with their embodiment yeah yeah but but
you know
uh i just recently saw that on twitter
there's far fewer women than men it's
mostly men who do this
twittering and facebook and so on yeah
well i think i think that what's
happened on twitter you know this might
i might be accused of tormenting my
theory past its justification i think
that
the fact that there's no direct to face
to face confrontation between men on
social media platforms facilitates a
female style of anti-social behavior
between men on social media platforms
okay yeah yeah because you see this
reputation savaging and it's like well
you don't do that in face-to-face
contact with a man because if i've seen
people repeatedly hundreds of times
not the same person but say something on
twitter
that no one would ever say face to face
to another adult male even once in their
life because it would immediately cause
well a movement towards physical
aggression if not an immediate punch
but that's not there and so then you
think well the fact that that's not
there what does that do
to the communication pattern and the
answer is we have no idea god only knows
what it does
so
maybe i could close with a couple of
general questions unless there's
something else that you would like to
suppose okay okay so um
i'm always curious about people's
intellectual heroes like i mentioned
some of the people who've been really
influential to me uh my loop my viewers
know freud jung
uh piaget
uh pankstep jeffrey gray like a handful
of well you a handful of animal
experimentalists uh some philosophers
like nietzsche uh solzhenitsyn for you
like who's been signal in your
intellectual development and and really
shaped your thinking
well the the founders of ethology which
were nicotenberger and conrad lawrence
they were very important i think they're
very different characters
uh but they they were very important for
my intellectual development uh ed wilson
i think was very important
um
uh
yeah i think wilson uh
and you know i was also influenced in
the beginning
by uh desmond morris's book uh the naked
eight yeah yeah yeah even though now if
i can easily mention quite a few things
that are uh not correct in that book uh
in terms of theories uh but the way he
wrote it and sort of irreverent way of
writing about the human species and and
sort of also and also making fun just
the idea that this comparison between
species was interesting ethically and
morally and emotionally that was kind of
revolutionary he did a good job of that
yeah his book was extremely successful
and partly because he had this tone of
mocking humans a little bit you know and
i think he did a
real good job at that
so yeah those were my early influences i
think you know
yeah one of the things that's so
interesting about your writing i think
is apart from its
remarkable approachability which i
really think is a gift is that
it's it's also
non-naively
positive and optimistic
which is so cool to see because that
those that does that combination doesn't
occur that often often people who are
optimistic are kind of naive but you're
a hardcore biologist
sort of in the in the scientific
trenches in a real sense and yet i
always come away from your books
with a positive
with a fundamentally positive
they have positive consequences on me
and you know the fact that you i think
your work on the biological basis of
moral development is
i think it's an
un of of of what would you say it's it's
kind of epoch level
philosophical significance you get such
a yeah
i'm an i'm an optimist by nature
and even though i started studying
violence and aggression because that was
the topic at the time everyone was
studying aggressive behavior
i very soon switched to conflict
resolution because i found i found it
actually more interesting than the
aggression itself well that's another
extremely cool you know that you got in
through the darkness so to speak but the
consequence of that was that you
actually learned that aggression and
violence weren't the fundamental basis
of social interaction and that
reconciliation
and competence and empathy and long-term
planning all of that actually turns out
to be more fundamental and important
yeah that's so optimistic that that
could possibly be true
and and i must say i don't enjoy
violence so so i have colleagues who
will
tell you a horrible story about two
chimps killing each other or
or people who watch sports games where
there's a lot of violence and and i you
know i've seen a lot of violence among
the primates i can tell you i know but
about it
but i don't enjoy it it's it's it's i
prefer when they get together afterwards
and groom each other
right right well that's interesting too
because that mean that actually made you
capable of seeing that when you did see
it
you know and and that's really something
yeah well your work man your work has
really been a cardinal influence on me
and i've been able to talk about it with
all these people like i talked to i know
150 000 people publicly in the last
three or four months and making this
case that
the fundamental basis of human social
organization is much better construed as
reciprocity and the spirit of play and
the ability to reconcile and
and
and that's such a people just don't hear
that and to know that that's grounded in
his solid scientific literature as well
as you know being the target of ethical
conceptualization it's it's so helpful
to put that other
uh
foundation underneath the claims that
you know
there's real reasons to be optimistic
about the nature of social organization
and individual motivation and your work
on gender differences and your support
in some sense for male ambition in that
regard it's also i think unbelievably
important so
i really appreciated you talking to me
today
it's a pleasure to meet you
yeah let's not talk on you